all right ready to waiting for the for
coming 55 ladder noodles some 50 said
roll and 75 or butter it's like you've
calorie Asperger's
that's not breakfast neither is coffee
you do a lot of sit-ups I'm not going to
treat you if you aren't interested in
living good speech pardon under control
very funny is the cake under you okay
honey
I just got to fact
Oh welcome to our new house member Allen
hi
although how do you do it eat I mean
local Ally I'm really [ __ ] hunger
[Music]
huh I feel kind of angry it's my life
too I don't get to have a sister what's
going on with you I just don't see great
people say they love you what what they
mean is they love how loving you makes
them feel about themselves they even
know where to start with that has all
kinds of wrong
[Music]
way that you're going one day you won't
wake up I can't stop every time you hear
that voice I want you to tell it to [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off boy
somebody tell me why we're here and
we're alive
very good
[Music]
some of them actually seem like they're
giving okay like they might get lives
and be scientist in people did you just
say something optimistic I did say some
I
you
you